[Music]
I would imagine that you have had offers
to do a series before well you've done
stuff before but what was it about this
now that I'm thinking about it you can
what was about this though that said I
have to make this I want to be a part of
this
well the long-form storytelling is very
interesting because it's character
driven and when I did the first thing
that I ever tried in this genre which
was wayward Pines and got to work with
Blake Crouch and we talked about big
ideas and movements that was for a
network and had a different kind of
language and parameters that you have to
tell the story and so I was in my mind I
wanted to do when I ever joined it again
the long-form story I wanted to have a
certain palette that I was hitting and
was allowed to hit and kind of a
darkness or a weirdness this kind of
just all came to be it has a minimalism
to it that I that I've truly loved has a
play like quality to it as as things get
bigger and bigger and bigger I want to I
want to go smaller and smaller and
smaller and I use that as the kind of
opposite weapon you directed I believe
two episodes yeah how many were you
thinking at one point me and I might
want to direct the whole series well I
it was so rewarding to work with other
directors I picked all the directors and
and even now as we're doing the second
season I'm picking all the directors I
watch a film and international film and
I go let me get on the phone with him or
her and say hey I'm interested in this
would you come and do an episode or two
for me this has been a great joy for me
to work with other people and and we
shoot it there it's right in Philly in
this and I literally we I hang with the
directors we watch dailies together and
I said hey why did you do that is this
important maybe you want to try that
again and we collaborate a lot so I felt
very connected to every episode and one
in nine with episodes that I directed a
first season four particular story
reasons if you've seen them you'll know
why I've seen an episode I've seen the
first five okay and I understand episode
1 I will watch
I guess the ninth and the not-so-distant
future one of the things I really think
that's cool about the series is that
it's very realistic in terms of if these
people were in this environment yeah
dealing with this situation this could
be what you
would happen you sort of talk about that
I love that kind of slightly manic
over-the-top humorous tone to dark humor
that the show has I really love that as
a thing I mean in the visit and split
and glass I'm really interested in that
type of kind of storytelling but it
needs to have a reason underneath it
there's a reason the person is acting
manic or hyper and so it has a ground at
understanding you really enjoy the fact
that everything is hyped but there's a
reason I had to look away from the
screen during the Eocene were you on set
that day yeah yeah it was pretty fun
pretty fun they shot that for quite a
while because uh they everyone's been
very clear that no animals were but like
I give credit like it's not often I have
to look away from a screen yeah I it was
it was it was something everybody was
very nervous about how to shoot this how
to make this as gruesome as we were
intending it to be and make you almost
faint when you're watching it and I
remember when they were shooting in and
we were editing in and how to make and
once we once we did everything that we
were gonna do to its CGI and this kind
of thing to take away all the tricks
that we did to make it look real it was
really disturbing to watch when I was in
the editing room and what with the
editor and every time we tweaked it or
moved it I would wince and watch it was
it was really fun and yet that is how
it's made oh absolutely um when you when
you went in to talk to Apple about doing
this series how much were they saying to
you do you have a plan for three years
you have a plan for five years and how
much is it sort of like we just want to
be in business with you we have faith
that you know what you're doing I think
from there and it was more open-ended
they were just very interested in me
telling this story for them for me it
was very very important that I know
where aspirationally where I want to go
how long will it take me to get there in
my head I know the last episode in my
head where we're going with the
characters and so that that those veins
come all the way back to episode 1 and
so I can tell the actors I can lean them
this way that way they can get lost and
move along the way but they'll never
that Northstar because I'm clear about
it so for me it's important this you get
all the benefits of this long form which
is character character character but if
you know the end point which is so rare
you can have that underlying muscle
structure under it that you're
unconsciously being pulled towards this
end point well I think also as a viewer
I want to know I like it when the
creators can tell me we know where we're
going yes because it's a more rewarding
experience for me to know that you know
it's all gonna tie together I think why
Tony and I worked so well together is
because of that he's very kind of
instinctual and tonal and I'm very
architectural I said this is where we
want to get to by this by the end of
this season and then this season and
then this is where our end goal is we
don't have to figure out everything
right now but we do know where we're
going and that will evoke in him these
ideas and we can talk about stuff that
won't get us into a corner because
that's what ends up happening is you do
you make when in this form you can make
decisions that corner you because wow
that sounds interesting we're gonna add
this aspect there'll be a giraffe okay
we'll put a giraffe on the street and
then you're you're stuck and how do you
well now that we have giraffes that are
on the street how do we get you know so
you you really if you know you're nord
start it actually strangely easy freedom
uh I'm thinking about the polar bear and
lost right now one of the things that by
the way I love lost go on record but I'm
just I've lost my train of thought on
that way I'm gonna switch gears
completely I want to ask you a separate
question yeah you have two movies
scheduled for 2021 and 2023 yeah very
excited when these things were announced
I have to ask you are these two movies
connected because or are they completely
separate things really completely
separate things actually I just had two
movie ideas in my head felt very strong
about it yeah for me there's the kind of
I have all these ideas and they're in
journals sometimes and they're they
don't quite have the meat yet so they
haven't whatever that thing is that
ineffable thing that makes it I'm ready
to come in two years in my life to
making this writing and directing this
and then promoting it it's some of those
ideas don't have those yet they just
have to just state a little bit but
there were two that I that I've been
thinking about that I was right away
these are these two I'm gonna make
and interestingly off there might be a
third a third thing that came to me that
might end up going in between these two
so but what so there might be there
might be three that's first of all as a
fan of yours that's awesome yeah
second of all can you do you have titles
for any of these ah
first one have you announced it or no no
so you're not gonna tell me no it's
changed already you from eat the last
draft that I wrote of it had a title and
I'm a now I'm thinking of slightly
altering the title in the in the six
draft of it got it and my last thing for
you um you you how do you think these
films that you're making compared to the
ones you've made before yeah is there
anything that is is one of them
radically different do they have a
similar like sort of knights truck you
know what I mean yeah well I'm loving
this approach from the visit on which is
minimal contained I own them
we take big risks tonal risks and we we
go try to hit that note of absurd but
grounded that that that that dark humor
moment and deal with some complicated
things and not necessarily take the
audience where they're comfortable both
during it or even at the end and but
that's all mitigated because we're
making it for a responsible number and I
feel like I'm being a good partner to my
distributors and I like that because it
allows me to iterate really fast in in
the making of these stories so those
films will follow that that architecture
of approach of process if even if it's
even it's me tricking me myself into
being more dangerous it's it's working
because I feel when I think about these
three films that I'm thinking about
they're all weird and dark and and I
think that they all speak to each other
a little bit so hopefully serving will
make you go oh wow I yeah right there
was a formalism to Betty Buckley's
character and where she worked in split
oh wow I see all these common threads
that are coming in underneath the piece
so hopefully they they they're good to
each other brothers and sisters I gotta
go but that's the thing that I think a
lot of people don't realize if you're
making a film for a lower budget you can
do whatever the f you want that's that's
really my philosophy yeah totally I
can't wait thank you so much for
everything
this was great thanks brother